i think they're in the opposite of
control i think they uh are in a really
tight spot here um
you know fundamentally if you zoom out a
little bit
the
fed can't raise rates to whip inflation
here um without uh basically bankrupting
everything
uh there is so much debt in the system
both at the sovereign and the corporate
level
that if you allow rates to rise
um
people become insolvent really quickly
uh and you could say crypto is a canary
in the coal mine there so
um if you look back at the 1970s when
was the last time we had inflation this
bad
um
paul volcker raised rates to 20 or
thereabouts
and uh that was a contributing factor in
um you know containing inflation
now
if you raise rates to five percent
uh the u.s government would default
right because our debt to gdp ratio is
120 as opposed to 30 as it was back then
and our deficit is around seven percent
this year
as opposed to uh two three percent as it
was back then so the system cannot
tolerate
uh rising interest rates
um so i don't actually believe that the
fed can sort of carry out their stated
agenda i know they're talking really
tough and they're posturing but i think
what's actually in store for us is
something more like yield curve control
which we're seeing in japan right now
where you're capping yields at a very
low rate and you're printing unlimited
amounts of fiat in order to cap those
yields
uh because
i don't think there's appetite for um
you know cutting
entitlement spending or defense spending
or anything like that so austerities out
of the picture
um
and i don't think there's appetite for
default obviously the us government's
never gonna default
so uh the only thing that we can
actually do here
uh is actually an inflationary pivot
here now i don't know what the effect of
that will be on asset prices but um
things are already breaking in the
financial system if you look closely
we're seeing basically any macro chart
that you look at
um whether it's two year
treasuries
uh whether it's the price the yen
uh whether it's mortgage-backed security
market uh all of these things are
showing enormous stress and the rapidity
of these moves is breathtaking uh so i
think the fed is actually going to be
responding to that um some commentators
say they have a shadow third mandate
which is the orderly functioning of the
bond market
as that bond market starts to break and
it is breaking uh my opinion if you look
at a lot of these indicators they're
going to have to revisit their sort of
proposed agenda here
a couple of weeks ago i was talking to
folks and and i said that uh while i
would not bet on it i do think that
there's an outsized chance that we will
actually get a rate cut before the end
of the year is that your viewpoint as
well or how do you think about like
where this goes through the end of
december yeah i share the view of
commentators like zoltan pozar or luke
roman or lynn alden that basically
it would be
genuinely impossible especially in an
election year
for the fed to
keep hiking here because that crushes
asset prices that reduces tax receipts
tax receipts are basically a function of
asset prices now
um it uh crushes the economy
and um you know it's basically sending
us not into recession territory but into
depression territory right now if they
continue on their sort of trajectory uh
so i don't believe that they're going to
do that because that would be an insane
thing to do uh and i believe that uh
they'll reverse course i think they just
started reducing uh their balance sheet
as of a couple days ago um
i yeah i don't fundamentally i don't
think the us can even handle four
percent um
rates here um it's just you know the
amount of debt leverage that's built up
is so so considerable if you had to pick
an over under how high they get before
they reverse course is it like two
percent three percent two and a half
percent i would say uh the reversal
um
will come no later than q4 this year q4
yeah um ecb holding an emergency meeting
i think last night or this morning um
how do you read into like other central
banks right obviously the ecb has said
hey we're gonna keep rates negative uh
we don't care what the fed's doing we're
going to kind of break from them then
they reverse course and they said oh
actually maybe we'll go back to kind of
zero percent interest rates and then
we'll follow now they have emergency
rate meetings like it just seems chaotic
like what are these other central banks
thinking in regards to the fed yeah i
will admit i'm sort of like quite
parochial so i'm mostly a fed watcher
and i don't really understand what's
going on in europe it just seems insane
um i would say like fundamentally
europe's problem is that they
um you know have an energy crisis and
sort of like everything follows from
that uh the other problem is that
they're trying to unite all these
disparate economies um under a single
monetary policy which uh doesn't seem to
work and it ends up just being highly um
you know leading to inegalitarian
outcomes and they've got this one blunt
weapon
um
the central bank you know aside from the
us i'm watching right now is japan
um they're imposing yield curve control
right so they're capping yields i think
at 25 basis points
and um even though they've unlimited
funds to um
keep you know keep the pressure uh
impose that ceiling on yields um
incredibly i think it traded above 25
basis points uh a couple days ago
um which is crazy because you're trading
in something with infinite ammo the
printing press um and so uh and the yen
is um is you know depreciating
enormously rapidly as a consequence of
that so that kind of is a i think that's
a glimpse into our future
uh is yield curve control keeping rates
low in order to keep the government
solvent and then the exit valve is
the dollar